bienvenue dans le débat de France 24 en
Israël à 73 ans beniani Netanyahu
pourrait redevenir Premier ministre
après les législatives d'hier les 5e en
trois ans et demi toujours pas de
résultats définitifs mais selon les
dernières projets sont partis de droite
le liquide obtient une trentaine de
siège sur 120 devant le parti du
centriste yaillir lapide et avec le
soutien des ultra orthodoxes et de
l'extrême droite il devrait franchir le
seuil des 61 sièges pour ainsi avoir la
majorité alors les jeux sont-ils faits
comment expliquer ce retour sur le
devant de la scène de benyanim Netanyahu
pourtant jugé pour corruption dans une
série d'affaires s'il s'allie avec les
ultra-orthodoxes et l'extrême droite
pour revenir au pouvoir quels seront les
conséquences politiques dans le pays
mais aussi pour les Palestiniens comment
est perçu à l'étranger le probable
retour de celui qu'on surnomme Bibi et
bien en débattre avec nos invités ce
soir Marc Lefebvre membre du Parti de
gauche de gauche un parti allié de hier
lapide bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous en plateau en plateau
également en face de vous s'il vient
Sylvain s'y pèle ancien directeur de la
rédaction de Courrier international
ancien rédacteur en chef du monde auteur
notamment de l'État d'Israël contre les
Juifs aux éditions La Découverte et de
les emmener la société israélienne dans
l'impasse bonsoir bonsoir si je peux
ajouter justement de la rédaction
d'Orient 21 voilà merci beaucoup Sylvain
sipel nous sommes également depuis
Jérusalem avec Michel ben ami membre du
comité central du liquide et puis à
Jérusalem avec nous également Vincent
Lemire historien directeur du centre de
recherche français à Jérusalem co-auteur
avec Christophe Gauthier de histoire de
Jérusalem aux éditions Les Arènes qui
est sorti le 27 octobre dernier si vous
le voulez bien on va d'abord regarder
les images de la soirée après l'annonce
des premiers résultats puis on va on va
commenter ça juste après c'est un sujet
qui est signé Bilal Tarabet
[Applaudissements]
le public chante bibi roi d'Israël
je ne suis pas roi
je dois être élu et c'est vous qui allez
me dire danyamine Netanyahou est de
nouveau on porte du pouvoir
nous avons rapporté aujourd'hui
un vote de confiance
le liquide et le plus grand parti
d'Israël
une fois qu'on aura des résultats finaux
je ferai un gouvernement d'union
nationale
les estimations donnent le liquide en
tête mais surtout donne à sa coalition
la majorité absolue 61 sièges et ce
grâce à un homme ita marque benvir son
alliance d'extrême droite sionisme
religieux et donner troisième formation
au Parlement
ah c'est beau les gens veulent des
dirigeants qui protègent la terre
d'Israël qui veulent développer le Nord
et le Sud du pays protéger sa capitale
Jérusalem et colonisé la Judée et la
Samarie
mais avec un retard d'un siège seulement
le Premier ministre sortant hier Lapid
veut croire que la situation peut
basculer
jusqu'à ce que la dernière enveloppe
soit ouverte rien n'est perdu
contrairement aux dernières élections
qui ont vu le départ de Benyamin
Netanyahou les parties arabes se sont
présentés en ordre dispersé une
certitude le taux de participation à ces
élections législatives et le plus élevé
qu'a connu le pays depuis plus de 20 ans
Michel benamy bonsoir
Benyamine Netanyahou semble avoir réussi
son pari le liquide en tête sur près de
90% maintenant des bulletins dépouillés
est-ce qu'il faut encore rester prudent
ou ça y est vous revendiquez la victoire
puisqu'on a déjà plus de 61 voies
jusqu'à demain à cette heure-ci on aura
100% des voix on saura si on a et entre
61 et 69 voies à la cnesset mais la
majorité elle est déjà elle est absolue
c'est fini c'est derrière nous et c'est
pas vraiment un pari des tanyahou était
en pause de un an et demi quand on fait
la comparaison de ce qui s'est passé
c'est aux élections d'avant c'est tout
simplement un parti qui était à droite
qui est passé à gauche et qui s'est fait
nommer Premier ministre Nathalie Bennett
et cette fois-ci il a disparu
complètement c'est tout le changement
dans la politique israélienne et à la
place de naphtali Bennett on a quelqu'un
qui a encore plus à droite et qui a
aucune chance qui passe et qui fasse ce
que Bennett a fait en passant à gauche
et il s'appelle itama c'est toute la
différence dans la politique israélienne
pendant ce un an et demi qu'on a passé
c'est tout
le premier Miss sortant affirmé dans la
nuit que tant que tous les bulletins
n'étaient pas comptés rien n'était joué
est-ce que il y a encore quelque chose
qui peut qui peut changer la donne
notamment justement mes rêves ou encore
un petit parti arabe qui pourrait faire
son entrée à l'acné
l'intégrale nationale avec un
pourcentage un seuil
d'éligibilité qui est fixée à 4 membres
de laknes 7 il faut que les parties
dépassent 3,25% des voix et à partir de
ces 3,25% de dépasser ils peuvent avoir
quatre députés donc on est un peu dans
une partie de poker parce que au jour
d'aujourd'hui 86% des bulletins ont été
dépouillés et quand on additionne les
voies du bloc de droite et d'extrême
droite face au bloc
dirigé par la pile plus les voix arabes
on a une différence de
0,01%. donc très peu d'accord donc ce
système proportionnel avec un seuil
effectivement accentue les moindres
décalage et quand un parti ne passe pas
le seuil et qu'il faut donc redistribuer
les les sièges on tombe sur l'image sur
laquelle sur laquelle on est
actuellement il y a encore des surprises
et encore 640 000 bulletins de vote à
dépouiller donc un peu plus de 10%. si
je prends le cas du parti dont je suis
membre Meretz qui est à 0,1% du seuil de
3,25 si vous suivez les chiffres ça veut
dire que il faudrait que sur les 640 000
bulletins qui restent à dépouiller il
est 3,7% des voix c'est-à-dire 23000
voix bon ça peut se jouer mais une fois
qu'on a dit ça à une fois qu'on sort un
petit peu de l'arithmétique électorale
je pense que ce qui est intéressant pour
noter les spectateurs c'est de
comprendre pourquoi un politicien
corrompu allié à des parties extrémistes
d'extrême droite
obtient grosso modo 50% des suffrages et
je pense que la gauche et le camp modéré
en général
a peut passer peut-être un peu trop de
temps à dénoncer ces porteurs de de
discours raciste d'extrême droite etc
etc
et à éviter de se poser la question
pourquoi la population est sensible à
ces discours donc on regarde plutôt on
regarde les effets mais il faudrait
s'attacher aux causes et je pense que
c'est ça qui est important et qui
pourrait être important pour le débat
plutôt que des dénonciations
confortables Vincent Lemire justement
comment expliquer ce retour de benyanim
Netanyahu benyanim Netanyahou pourtant
cerner par des affaires ça ça n'a pas
découragé les électeurs
écoutez ça je suis d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit c'est une leçon pour la
gauche Israël ils le sont pour toutes
les gauches occidentales le vote contre
n'a pas suffi et le socle le socle
électoral de Benyamine Nathan Yahoo
n'est absolument pas sensible à ces
casserole qu'il traîne voir saint leur
enfant ça le consolide parce que ça veut
dire qu'il est l'ennemi du système
l'ennemi les élites et donc là on a une
c'est là aussi que la situation
israélienne est intéressante et nous
intéresse au-delà de la d'Israël et de
la Palestine et du Moyen-Orient c'est
que c'est une situation qui intéresse
toutes les forces politiques en Occident
et on a vu que au Brésil voilà Lula a
réussi sur le fil à battre bolsonaro
Biden sur le fil à battre Trump mais on
voit qu'on a cette poussée des parties
extrémistes et on a cette gauche morale
qui effectivement comme ça vient d'être
dit
[Musique]
n'appuie que sur le ressort du du vote
moral il faut éviter ce scandale d'un
homme corrompu qui reviendrait au
pouvoir mais en fait qui échoue à
véritablement proposer quelque chose de
positif pour le pays il faut savoir que
vu d'ici vu de vu d'Israël la campagne
s'est fait aussi beaucoup sur des
questions socio-économiques sur comme
comme partout le niveau de vie est en
baisse l'inflation extrêmement forte
donc il y a aussi des questions
socio-économiques et là de ce point de
vue là nathanyahou c'était pratiquement
l'essentiel de son message il avait deux
messages pendant cette campagne c'était
la lutte contre la hausse des prix et ne
vous abstenez pas voilà il a appuyé
là-dessus pendant deux mois il a fait de
fait une excellente campagne moi je peux
pas je peux absolument pas vous dire que
je suis étonné j'ai pris mon risque hier
j'étais plusieurs fois à l'antenne sur
France Info de la mi-journée et quand
j'ai vu les taux de participation très
très élevé et qu'on a compris que
c'était pas dans des bureaux de vote des
des Palestiniens de nationalités
israélienne que la mobilisation se
faisait il était certain que Nathan
Yahoo allait allait avoir cette poussée
donc moi je suis pas du tout dans
l'arithmétique nathan est a gagné et
sans doute pas avec 61 député sans doute
avec 63 64 65 il a une majorité absolue
et il va effectivement gouverner avec
l'extrême droite
israélienne elle n'a pas su parler
justement aux électeurs israéliens de
l'inflation des problèmes du quotidien
de la sécurité c'est ça qu'ils
attendaient les électeurs sans doute
mais je pense que la faillite de la
gauche israélienne n'a pas commencé un
matin c'est pas cette année que la
gauche n'a pas su la gauche n'est
a disparu du paysage politique
soignant même si mes rêves obtenait par
exemple le passé cette fois-ci le le
seuil qui permettrait de rentrer en tout
et pour tout le travail ont quatre élus
et mes rêves seraient quatre élus ça
fait 8 élus
ça veut dire que
le toute cette gauche réunie aurait la
moitié des voies de ce que benvir a eu
c'est ça que ça signifie donc ebenvir
n'est que la fraction la plus extrémiste
de cette nébuleuse de la de la grotte de
l'extrême droite israélienne alors il y
a deux il y a deux manières de voir un
peu ce qui s'est passé soit on peut
comme on l'a dit on peut insérer ce qui
se passe en Israël un phénomène
international c'est vrai qu'il y a un
phénomène international en Italie même
en France
alors on peut l'insérer et il y a de
bonnes raisons de l'insérer et
d'ailleurs l'État d'Israël entretient
les meilleurs relations les
gouvernements récents ont entretenu les
meilleures relations avec maudit en 1
avec Orban avec ce qu'on appelle des
gouvernements il libéraux on ne dit pas
qu'ils sont anti libéraux mais ils ne
sont plus libéraux voilà ils sont plus
c'est une manière de dire qu'ils sont
plus vraiment démocrate une autre
manière de regarder cette élection c'est
à dire que
le renforcement numérique de l'extrême
droite n'est pas énorme en réalité
quand on regarde par rapport à des
scrutins précédents c'est un peu mieux
mais c'est pas du tout spectaculaire en
revanche ce qui est spectaculaire c'est
que ça soit benguille ça c'est
spectaculaire et l'alliance entre
bengwir et motrices
pour gagner cette élection
fondamentalement il est parvenu à réunir
et à les convaincre les deux se
détestent l'un l'autre il se déteste
mais ces deux personnes qui veulent
incarner le sionisme religieux le plus
extrême
il est parvenu à obtenir deux ils vont
peut-être se diviser bientôt mais il est
parvenu à obtenir deux qui se réunissent
et ils ont fait un score tout à fait
inattendu
ça c'est un changement c'est un
changement c'est une continuité de
toutes les évolution d'Israël parce que
on peut pas s'étonner de ce succès ça a
été préparé depuis 25 ans en revanche
évidemment le succès de benvir est
indicatif d'un changement plus profond
c'est et là j'ai pris les articles de
Arès de ce matin et la crainte
principale il parle pas tellement de ce
qui va arriver au Palestiniens
et autoritaire dont le but est de
détruire l'infrastructure démocratique
la crainte de ce journal qui est quand
même le principal journal de référence
d'Israël c'est de il parle pas tellement
des Palestiniens bien sûr ils ont des
inquiétudes vis-à-vis de la politique de
gouvernement par rapport au Palestiniens
mais surtout ils sont des inquiétudes
par rapport à la démocratie en Israël et
c'est là où il y a sincèrement un
changement notoire parce que ce sont pas
seulement des îles libéraux et en
particulier bengwir et smot sont des
gens très radicaux et la justice en
Israël et la démocratie peuvent en subir
de graves justement j'aimerais qu'on
regarde un portrait dit et puis on va en
reparler après
contraire
des consignes de vote claire jusqu'au
moment de glisser son bulletin dans
l'urne un franc-parlé de la provocation
c'est la méthode Itamar bengwir ce
député d'extrême droite devenu en
quelques années la coqueluche des
suprémacistes israéliens sa formation
ultra radicale baptisée sionisme
religieux et qu'il partage avec des
allèles motrices un autre nationaliste a
bousculer la campagne de ce scrutin
législatif elle pourrait devenir la
troisième force politique à l'acnée
celte
les jeunes m'aiment tellement et je leur
dis si je deviens le ministre de la
Sécurité Intérieure alors ce sera bien
il y aura du calme dans les rues
46 ans et père de 6 enfants vit dans
l'une des colonies les plus radicales de
si Jordanie occupés un avocat de
formation ouvertement raciste et
homophobes qui défend l'annexion de la
scie Jordanie et le transfert d'une
partie de la population arabe d'Israël
vers les pays voisins
il n'y a pas vraiment de peuple
palestinien historiquement nous avons
toujours vécu ici le peuple palestinien
est un terme récent vieux de quelques
décennies il y a les Arabes qui peuvent
vivre en paix et en sécurité ici et je
n'ai aucun problème avec eux
cet ancien membre du mouvement cache
banni d'Israël puis son idéologie
anti-arabe dans celle du rabbin
extrémiste mais irkan Itamar bengwir
affirme vouloir sauver son pays et être
en guerre contre les djihadistes sa
formation d'extrême droite veut
également abroger les délits
d'escroquerie et d'abus de confiance
dans l'espoir de blanchir Benyamine
Netanyahou toujours aux prises avec la
justice
[Musique]
Michel ben ami vous faites partie du
liquide ça n'est pas un problème
aujourd'hui pour les électeurs du
liquide notamment de s'allier à des
parties comme ça à des hommes comme
Itamar benvir
d'abord je suis pas d'accord avec tout
ce que vous avez dit maintenant de ita
marbellir et je ne représente pas état
Marvel cette personne qui a surgit de
piano et demi elle n'a rien contre les
Arabes elle a jamais dit il a jamais dit
qu'il est pour un transfert j'aurais
bien voulu voir une vidéo ou ta Marvel
vire dit quelque chose contre la loi
israélienne automatiquement il ne me il
ne peut même pas se présente se
présenter à la cness c'est faux c'est
pas l'homme dont il s'agit je pense que
vous avez fait erreur avec Cana ou avec
d'autres que la loi en Israël ne lui
permet pas de se présenter d'être membre
du Parlement en Israël juste pour
rappeler ce que vous avez dit avant le
itama benkir et vous avez emmené à
représentant même parti mérite ce qui ne
passe pas à la knees 7 et qui est contre
le système un autre qui veut changer les
règles du jeu en Israël ou peut-être
changer le peuple en Israël le peuple
veut la droite il y en a eu beaucoup de
problèmes pendant un an et demi que ce
soit de la sécurité que ce soit dans
l'économie et on est tous le peuple et
en manque de ce qu'il y avait pendant 24
ans quand il y avait un Premier ministre
qui était biniami Netanyahou ou Arielle
charol ou des gens de droite qui ont
géré cet état le mieux possible pendant
un an et demi ça fait que des gringoler
on est revenu
en place pour rattraper pour améliorer
pour arranger pas pour détruire pas pour
mettre quelqu'un dehors pas pour eux
qu'on appelle nos
conjoints à la CNES l'extrême droite
c'est quoi l'extrême droite parce qu'ils
sont le plus à droite dans la politique
israélienne ou parce que comme vous avez
dit dans votre rapport que il parle d'un
transfert de population non c'est faux
personne ne parle de transfert de
population en Israël et si on a
quelqu'un qui parlera de transfert de
population en Israël il ne pourra pas
être membre de la clé 7 ni membre de la
co de netanyah ou en tout cas donc on va
calmer on n'est pas du tout là où vous
avez emmené dans ce débat et c'est la
même chose qu'on avait il y a un an et
demi sauf au lieu de naphtali Bennett on
a etama oui quelqu'un qui est à droite
comme naphtali Bennett mais qui ne
partira en aucun cas avec un
gouvernement de gauche c'est tout c'est
toute la différence même au niveau des
chiffres marque Lefèvre qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à Michel Beney
surpendante du liquide est un est un
beau discours pour l'exportation
qui n'a rien à voir avec la teneur des
discours et des controverses politiques
qui ont lieu en Israël mais c'est pas
tellement ça qui m'intéresse
par rapport à ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure sur les dangers pour la
démocratie
il faut bien comprendre que les critères
démocratiques les valeurs culturelles et
politiques sont extrêmement diversifiées
dans la société israélienne il y a une
minorité démographique
d'Israéliens qui sont sur des
référentiels culturels politiques et
moraux équivalent au référentiel
européen je vous donnerai simplement un
exemple
dont j'ai été témoin il y a plusieurs
années il y avait eu ce qu'on appelle le
mouvement des tentes ou des jeunes qui
étaient en difficulté économique en
difficulté de logement se sont installés
sur la principale artère de Tel-Aviv le
boulevard Rothschild et on campait
pendant des semaines avec leur
revendications qui étaient des
revendications sociales puisqu'ils
avaient des difficultés de niveau de vie
de logement etc etc c'était une classe
moyenne
urbaine
occidentalisée moi j'habitais et je
travaillais à ce moment-là dans le
négave à bercheva et j'avais autour de
moi une population sociologiquement
ethniquement complètement différente une
majorité de Juifs d'origine horizontal
et beaucoup de Russes
beaucoup d'Israéliens d'origine russe
qui était là depuis 10-15 ans en Israël
mais qui qui était là depuis déjà pas
mal de temps et quand je discutais avec
eux de ce mouvement social politique de
revendications etc etc
l'idée même de descendre dans la rue
pour défendre les revendications
collectives
communes à tout un secteur de la
population leur était totalement
étrangère
il faut savoir qu'en Israël ce qui
fonctionne et c'est favorisé par le par
le système électoral c'est le
clientélisme c'est chacun pour soi
chacun pour sa communauté pour son
secteur si Benyamine est un Yahoo arrive
au pouvoir c'est pas pour le bien-être
de toute la population il a fait un deal
avec des parties d'extrême droite il a
fait un deal avec les rares dim sur le
financement des écoles
du système scolaire des religieux ultra
orthodoxes voilà c'est avec des deals
politiques israélien qui qui crée ce
besoin
sur un arrière-plan de monter des
extrémismes de l'extrême droite un peu
partout il y a des particularités
spécifiques à la société israélienne et
il y a quelque chose dont on n'a pas
encore parlé qui est le fait que Israël
occupe depuis 1967 des territoires qui
sont qui sont des territoires qui ne l'a
pas qui ne lui appartiennent pas et
toutes les passions cette occupation
quelque part elle pervertit en
profondeur la nécessité de maintenir
cette occupation avec tout ce que ça
implique au niveau économique au niveau
militaire au niveau sécurité avec
effectivement une difficulté de toute
façon à avoir des partenaires avec
lesquels on pourrait trouver des
solutions courageux et alternatives
quelque part ça influe négativement
aussi sur toutes les perspectives
morales et toute la solidité morale et
éthique de la société israélienne et et
à partir du moment où une des priorités
et le chiffon rouge qu'on affiche
régulièrement pour nous surtout évacuer
toutes les questions sociales de
l'occupation quelque part ça favorise un
sionisme
radical messianique et religieux qui
effectivement est de plus en plus fort
qui présente une solution qui est la
solution de perpétuer pour l'éternité
cette occupation alors qu'on sait très
bien que à l'horizon de d'une génération
ou de deux générations s'il n'y on a une
solution et une solution donnée aux
revendications nationales des
Palestiniens on sera dans une situation
où il y aura une un secteur géographique
où la majorité ne serait plus juive et
où on sera pour ceux qui sont porteurs
d'un mouvement sioniste progressiste et
laïque on sera dans une situation
insupportable Vincent Lemire est-ce que
il y a un risque aujourd'hui pour la
démocratie israélienne je reviens à ce
que disait tout à l'heure Sylvain CIPEL
qui cité à arêtes Israël et sur le point
d'entamer une révolution de droite
est-ce que le système aujourd'hui le
système politique tel qu'il est étant
danger avec cette alliance qui se
profile entre benyanime Netanyahu les
ultras orthodoxes et l'extrême droite
écoutez en tout cas c'est ce que la
gauche et le centre en Israël craignent
un risque publié un article juste avant
les élections le titre de l'article
c'était cet article pourrait ne plus
être publié sous le prochain
gouvernement donc il y a vraiment une
plainte y compris pour la liberté
d'expression
ceci étant je suis malheureusement
obligé d'être d'accord en tant
qu'historien avec ce avec ce qu'a dit
Michel Bennani le peuple d'Israël veut
la droite et je crois que Netanyahu
avait été écarté la dernière fois
effectivement sur sur une coalition
extrêmement hétéroclite avec le avec le
soutien effectivement des des
Palestiniens d'Israël mais ça ne pouvait
pas tenir longtemps et je suis aussi
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit il tamark
bendy dans le dans le sujet les jeunes
m'aiment bien soyons précis bengwir fait
encore mieux chez les jeunes que dans
les populations les plus âgées et on est
obligé de dire que les parties de gauche
et y compris le Marais c'est y compris à
vos dalle et travailler ont un électorat
non seulement extrêmement faible
numériquement très faible sur le plan
quantitatif mais en plus vieillissant
donc ce qui arrive ce soir
c'est que le début d'une
extrême droitisation du
centre de la politique israélienne et là
pour le coup alors on comprend bien que
Michel benamy voilà comment ce soir mais
des hier soir les éléments de langage
ont été envoyés pour dire que Ben nous
vire c'est pas si terrible que ça se
motrices il est passé homophobe que ça
etc si ce sont des parties racistes
racialistes homophobe misogyne
misogyne également parce qu'on parle pas
de ça par exemple mais sur les 65 sur
les 65 élus a priori de la coalition de
Netanyahou il y aurait seulement 8
femmes 57 hommes 8 femmes la coalition
précédente de gangs sur 61 il y avait 24
femmes donc c'est aussi une menace pour
les femmes
en Israël c'est une menace pour les
couples de même sexe
aujourd'hui pour pour les minorités
arabes pour la communauté LGBT et pour
les femmes justement
écoutez une des déclarations de d'un des
membres de ce parti c'est pour un jeune
palestinien qui jette une pierre à un
soldat une balle dans la tête
pour un jeune colon qui jette une pierre
à un soldat
un peu d'éducation
voilà donc ce sont des parties crypto
fascistes racistes suprémacistes qui
arrivent au pouvoir pour la première
fois c'est dans la logique de l'histoire
c'est en historien que je que je dis ça
mais là où je suis encore plus inquiet
c'est que je pense que ce n'est que le
début parce que quand on regarde la
démographie du vote et quand on voit les
structures d'âge on se rend compte que
il y avait 250 000 votants de plus cette
fois-ci par rapport à la dernière fois
il y a aussi toute cette toute cette
immigration et tous ces tous ces jeunes
tous ces jeunes des collines tous ces
jeunes des colonies qui arrivent
maintenant en âge de voter et qui sont
et qui sont sur des positions politiques
extrêmes et qui sont très très à droite
de netany ou je sais pas pour nous pour
nos auditeurs qui nous regardent en
France voilà on est on est très très à
droite de Marine Le Pen et on est plutôt
à droite d'Éric Zemmour vous voyez voilà
ce qui est en train d'arriver j'aimerais
qu'on écoute à présent la réaction des
Palestiniens après ces résultats des
élections celui du porte-parole du Hamas
nous ne nous attendons pas un changement
de la politique sioniste à l'égard de
notre peuple si ce n'est une escalade
des agressions contre nos lieux saints
et notre peuple en Steve Jordanie et
dans la bande de Gaza ces élections ne
peuvent pas changer la politique
d'Israël elles vont plutôt renforcer le
consensus entre ces parties israéliens
pour refuser à notre peuple ses droits
fondamentaux il faut donc intensifier la
résistance et unifier la position
palestinienne
à quoi ils doivent attendre les
Palestiniens avec le retour de benyani
Netanyahou au pouvoir avec avec ses
alliés d'extrême droite
il y a un paradoxe le paradoxe c'est que
benguir incarne une version du
colonialisme voyou c'est-à-dire que
c'est un colonialisme de frappeur
le monsieur Benaïm un peu fait sourire
dans ce qu'il a expliqué sur sur le
nouveau saint bengwir mais vous savez il
avait chez lui j'étais connu de tout
Israël il avait dans son salon une très
grande photo de baoor golstein
c'est-à-dire de l'homme qui au Caveau
des Patriarches avait tué 29
musulmans en prière et il avait blessé
je crois une centaine de personnes
derrière quelque chose comme ça ça c'est
benvir si vous voulez donc donc qu'on
nous raconte ensuite mais non pas du
tout c'est un gentil garçon voilà alors
les Palestiniens ont à craindre ce sera
intéressant de savoir quel poste qui va
avoir il demande la police la sécurité
intérieure s'il obtient ça va
ce gouvernement ne va pas être simple du
tout malgré les apparences ils ont gagné
mais les années où on va se méfier c'est
compliqué et par ailleurs les ambitions
évidemment de ce groupe que représente
bengwir et motrices sont très importants
donc on verra par exemple si l'obtiendra
visiblement Netanyahou n'a pas
l'intention pour le moment on verra
ce qu'a dit la personne du ramasse et à
peu près frappé au coin du bon sens
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'il y a à
attendre d'un gouvernement de ce type
c'est pas un gouvernement différent des
précédents le paradoxe je le répète ça
me semble important c'est que
jusqu'ici ce qu'a fait Netanyahu c'est
sans arrêt balancé entre des opérations
militaires mais il en a pas fait trop
pas beaucoup et la plupart du temps
trouver des moyens de calmer la donne
pendant un an et demi deux ans trois ans
et il y est plutôt bien parvenu y
compris dans ces négociations parce que
la vérité c'est que le ramasse et des
méchants et tout mais en négocie avec
eux bon et donc il a négocié ça et il y
a il a pas trop mal fait
benguire peut et il doit s'en méfier et
je pense qu'il s'en méfiera bengwir peut
tout à fait le faire basculer dans
d'autres méthodes vis-à-vis des
Palestiniens c'est-à-dire il faut le
rappeler quand même qu'il y a encore
trois mois il a organisé des ratonnades
de véritables ratonnades de musulmans
près de la porte de Damas à à
Jérusalem donc si vous voulez c'est ça
ben gris
de ce point de vue là il y a une
possibilité de bascule qui est
absolument indéniable je sais alors par
ailleurs il y a les inquiétudes dans la
crainte de l'article que vous avez cité
à mon avis quand arrête disait un
pouvoir d'extrême droite religieux une
révolution d'extrême droite religieuse
et autoritaire le mot clé c'est
autoritaire
c'est ça le mot clé parce que l'extrême
droite religieuse et
l'extrême droite et la religion ils
étaient déjà au pouvoir et ces gens-là
étaient déjà au pouvoir avant benguir
benvir amène quelque chose qui est neuf
et effectivement c'est l'autoritarienne
et c'est la méthode forte Michel ben ami
ça va être compliqué pour baigner un
Netanyahu de constituer un gouvernement
du tout du tout y aller fait il y a les
paroles l'effet vous avez bien dit pour
Netanyahou on va parler du mal du mal
mais en fin de compte c'est jamais
quelqu'un qui a créé une guerre ou qui
est rentré en guerre ou qui je vais vous
dire plus que ça j'entends le ramasse
dans votre reportage
pas prendre des risques jamais
Netanyahoo on a créé on a commencé une
guerre il y a eu des c'est le seul
Premier ministre en Israël qui n'a pas
déclaré la guerre venant d'Israël
c'est-à-dire c'est clair ça c'est jamais
passé et c'est pour ça il y a l'effet il
y a les mots aussi pour benguir
j'entends cette histoire encore de
photos de Goldstein à la maison de
benguire il y a jamais eu de photos de
Goldstein à la maison de benguir j'étais
personnellement dans cette maison pour
voir cette photo et c'est pas vrai il y
a pas cette photo
rigoler jusqu'à demain personnellement
j'étais là-bas puisque ça on a demandé
plusieurs fois à bengwir si pour eux
soft on lui a demandé plusieurs trois
par rapport à cette histoire de photos
de gostein il a demandé à la caméra de
regarder plus que ça il a dit que pour
lui Goldstein était un terroriste comme
qui soit juif ou musulman quelqu'un qui
tue des gens qui n'ont rien fait
s'intéressent c'est les paroles de
benguir Je vous dire plus que ça benguir
c'est quelqu'un qui frappe partie d'une
coalition de netanyahua il veut faire
partie de cette coalition il va devoir
faire avec la façon de voir du liquide
et il est d'accord si bien changé la
donne il ne sera pas dedans il ne
cherche pas à changer la donne il veut
être ministre de de la police pas de
problème ça sera bien pour la population
musulmane que pour la population
israélienne le grand problème
aujourd'hui des meurtres dans la
situation en Israël c'est dans la
population musulmane eux-mêmes ils
viennent ils demandent à ce que la
police passe de 30 000 personnes à 60000
personnes qu'en règle ce problème qui se
passe dans les villages dans les villes
musulmanes en Israël
où est le problème c'est à dire dire des
phrases pour bien lui vous avez parlé de
arrête qui disent que il y aura un
gouvernement de droite qui va fermer
arrête jamais un gouvernement de droite
demandait à fermer un journal peu
importe lequel d'un autre côté il y a eu
un an et demi maintenant un gouvernement
de gauche qui a essayé de fermer la
seule télévision de droite en Israël
c'est tout à l'envers les faits sont
complètement de l'autre côté les paroles
pouvaient dire tout ce que vous voulez
montrez-moi une photo de Goldstein
puisque ça il y a la loi en Israël c'est
benguir vient et qui disent que pour lui
Goldstein n'est pas
un terroriste il ne peut pas se
présenter au Parlement israélien il y a
la loi
j'aimerais pas arrêter toutes ces
paroles toutes ces oui je vous entends
j'aimerais qu'on avance un petit peu et
qu'on aille voir un peu les réactions à
l'étranger voir comment est perçu le
très probable retour de benyanim
Netanyahou au pouvoir pour ça on va
partir aux États-Unis prochain ami
d'Israël retrouver Matthieu Mabin notre
correspondant Matthieu bonsoir pour
l'administration Biden le retour de
benyanim netanyaound n'est pas vraiment
une bonne nouvelle
oui au risque de répéter ce qu'il y a
déjà été dit sur votre plateau il faut
je crois relativiser cette idée même si
c'est vrai Dieu vaiden s'il avait eu le
choix n'aurait probablement pas fait
celui de Benyamin Netanyahou mais ça
n'est pas le cas ça n'est pas le choix
des Américains Joe Biden et Benjamin
Netanyahu néanmoins se connaissent bien
et même si leur leur partenance
respective des familles politiques qui
s'opposent compliquent leur dialogue au
moins en surface le positionnement
global de l'Amérique dans la région n'en
subit qu'une très faible influence
finalement pour preuve rien de ce qui a
été entrepris par l'administration Trump
durant les quatre années de son mandat a
réellement été modifié par
l'administration byden évidemment
l'ambassade des États-Unis reste à
Jérusalem le dialogue avec l'Autorité
palestinienne a concrètement pas été à
rétabli rétabli ou en tout cas à peine
symboliquement et clairement on a la
reprise du dialogue entre Israël et les
voisins arabes opérés par Donald Trump
bénéficie à l'administration
quotidiennement y compris à
l'administration Biden particulièrement
en ces périodes troublées même quand on
touche à de purs symboles comme le
consulat palestinien à Washington par
exemple consulat fermé sous Donald Trump
dans les premiers mois de son mandat
même cette action a forte portée
symbolique n'a pas été entreprises par
les démocrates américains et le consulat
demeure fermé quel que soit les
administrations en réalité qui se
succèdent à la Maison Blanche finalement
on trouve dans les grandes lignes de la
politique américaine au Proche-Orient
une forme de continuité on se souvient
évidemment des engagements de Barack
Obama des engagements forts pour une
solution à deux États mais il faudrait
une véritable révolution ici pour que
les États-Unis cessent d'être le
principal allié de l'Israël vous l'avez
rappelé on l'a dit Benjamin Netanyahou
et Joe Biden se connaissent bien il se
fréquente depuis des décennies et même
s'il y a des points de désaccord entre
les deux hommes la Maison Blanche
continuera à écouter la gauche
israélienne largement représ présenter
ici à Washington d'ailleurs mais la
Maison Blanche n'est absolument pas
prête à un bras de fer significatif avec
le gouvernement israélien aujourd'hui
l'accord sur la démarcation de la
frontière maritime entre Liban et Israël
a été largement encouragé par la
diplomatie américaine et il faut donc
après les déclarations nathanyahou sur
le sujet s'attendre à une passe d'armes
diplomatique au moins entre Jérusalem et
le département beta mais clairement dans
le climat actuel encore une fois la
pression internationale qui s'exerce sur
Joe Biden avec les dossiers chinois et
ukrainien pour ne citer que il ne faut
pas s'attendre à l'ouverture d'un
nouveau front diplomatique en tout cas
pas à l'initiative du président
américain merci beaucoup Mathieu Mabin
depuis Washington Vincent Lemire le
retour de benyanime Netanyahu au pouvoir
en Israël est-ce que ça va changer
quelque chose dans la région
alors oui ce que je suis d'accord avec
ce qui vient d'être dit mais avec quand
même une petite nuance d'abord il faut
faire quand même la part entre le entre
le gouvernement et l'opinion publique et
même du point de vue du gouvernement il
y avait un communiqué je me souviens
plus si c'était du de la Maison Blanche
ou du secrétaire d'État qui disait nous
avons hâte de travailler avec le futur
gouvernement israélien dans le respect
de nos intérêts de nos valeurs communes
on connaît le langage des diplomates ça
veut dire que il y a une vigilance en
tout cas de de l'administration Biden
vis-à-vis de ce futur probablement
israélien de droite et d'extrême droite
ça c'est la première chose mais il y a
aussi la question de l'opinion publique
et en particulier de l'opinion publique
de la communauté juive américaine et ce
qui s'est passé hier en Israël va
évidemment accentuer le fossé voir
désormais le divorce entre la communauté
juive américaine qui vote de plus en
plus démocrate on est pratiquement 80
85%
[Musique]
on mentionne souvent l'âge avancé
Joe Biden était vice-président quant
Obama était président et Joe Biden a de
la bonne mémoire il se souvient comment
Netanyahu a humilié le président Obama
comment Netanyahou c'est permis de faire
un discours contre le président des
États-Unis devant le devant le Sénat
américain le Congrès devant le Congrès
américain donc ce sont des choses qui ne
s'oublient pas mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les priorités des
États-Unis se sont
le conflit à long terme possible avec la
Chine et c'est actuellement la guerre la
guerre d'agression de la Russie en
Ukraine et sur ces deux questions le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il y a
un palestinienne aujourd'hui
il y a un large écart entre le
positionnement d'Israël sur ces
questions qui sont des priorités
actuellement pour les Américains et la
position d'Israël la position d'Israël
remonte les partisans du liquide
n'arrêtent pas de nous dire que grâce à
Netanyahu Israël est en position de
force Israël n'est pas en position de
force vis-à-vis de la Russie
Israël est en position de faiblesse
stratégique vis-à-vis de la Russie et
Israël les Américains ne se sont pas
non pas manqué de faire montrer à Israël
depuis longtemps que Israël était un peu
fragile et un peu naïf en ce qui
concerne les pénétrations technologiques
et économiques en particulier sur les
infrastructures de la Chine en Israël
donc il y a beaucoup de sujets
indépendants de la question
palestinienne sur lesquelles il y a des
différences entre Israël et les
États-Unis en ce qui concerne la
question palestinienne je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une priorité
pour les États-Unis qui ont d'autres
priorités je pense que pour que cette
question palestienne soit adressée
sérieusement il faudra aussi quelque
part que
il y a à la fois une volonté politique
et un peu d'audace et un peu activité du
côté israélien mais aussi peut-être
une une évacuation enfin une abolition
ou un amendement des rigidités et des
rigidités de la société Palestine donc
on est loin on est loin d'une solution
mais c'est occupation cette occupation
coron quelque part profondément dans les
racines même la société israélienne et
on envoie les on envoie les conséquences
négatives et on n'est pas à l'abri avec
ces nouveaux dirigeants messianiques et
fascisants on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
réaction de sursaut et de désespoir une
de plus du côté Palestine Michel benamy
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça
rapidement on a plus beaucoup de temps
le président américain jobidan était là
il y a quelques mois il a été chercher
miniami netanyao le chef de l'opposition
trois rangs derrière et quand on lui a
demandé que c'est hors du protocole il y
a Dinan c'est mon ami je veux lui parler
il a travaillé avec Benyamin Netanyahou
il travaillera avec biniami netanyaho il
n'y a aucun problème avec les États-Unis
ça n'a rien à voir qui est le chef des
États-Unis ou d'Israël ces deux pays qui
connaît que connectante aux gens par
rapport au Palestiniens à ce que vous
venez de dire le sort des Palestiniens
le problème palestinien il viendra à
terme s'il est Palestiniens eux-mêmes
viennent et se rendent compte qu'il faut
régler le problème il faut laisser
tomber le terrorisme essayer de créer un
pays on voit ce qui se passe à Gaza au
lieu de rendre Gaza Singapour c'est
c'est un pays où on peut même pas
appeler ça un pays c'est le ramasse qui
qui tire des obus et des missiles des
maisons des enfants et quand il y a un
retour c'est des enfants ou des maisons
qui vont toucher et Israël est là à ne
pas répondre parce qu'on veut pas que
des enfants qui sont déjà pris entre les
mains du ramasse qui leur fait tellement
de mal que nous on va ajouter c'est pour
ça les problèmes ici sont ils sont
autrement que ce qu'on parle des fois à
la télé il faut venir sur place faire
les choses comme il faut et en ce moment
le changement de de gouvernement qui
aura en Israël c'est d'abord et avant
tout des problèmes intérieurs c'est
c'est l'habitation qui a augmenté
énormément c'est le niveau de vie c'est
la sécurité aujourd'hui que on voit que
le terrorisme a augmenté etc ça n'a rien
à voir avec l'extérieur je pense que ça
soit gauche ou droite ça sera le même
accord avec le Liban ou le même souci
avec l'Iran et les problèmes et le
changement de gouvernement va faire face
plutôt à des problèmes internes en tout
cas les premiers mois les la première
année merci il y a rien à ce merci
Michel benami le dernier mot Sylvain
CIPEL très rapidement avant de se
quitter le dernier mot je pense que
Netanyahou a fait campagne contre
l'accord avec le Liban et que je pense
qu'il va s'y rallier il va faire parce
qu'il va pour toutes sortes de raisons
politiques ont donné des garanties au
Liban justement dans mais ça c'est
intéressant
merci beaucoup merci Marc Lefebvre on a
plus du tout le temps merci Sylvain
merci Michel bennamy merci Vincent
Lemire merci c'est la fin de ce débat
restez avec nous l'information continue
sur France 24
[Musique]